one two three four I would tell you
jittery oh go you know what they all try
to give him the rap show oh yeah this
funky rap I am rocking profiling I took
my old man and they got me well but he
ain't up there and they my plan to bring
people there cuz he's a Superman okay so
this is day three of hurricane no day
four of Hurricane sandy aftermath I am
up in a hotel in midtown Manhattan my
employers and MSNBC were nice enough to
put me up for and I have been staying
with my friends up in Upper West Side
great friends great employer I haven't
been back to my place in like three days
back down in Lower East Side which is
you know completely without power it's a
strange situation right now because it's
like half of the city is dark half the
city like down right now in lower
Manhattan it is like Mad Max Wild West
style you know people in dumpsters
trying to get food crowding around surge
protectors to charge their cell phones
it's crazy
obviously the the power being out is not
as bad as the way some people happen
right now which is you know I'm talking
about the Jersey Shore where there's
just scenes of devastation houses are
torn up people have unfortunately passed
away in the storm it's it's it's
terrible so you really can't complain
even for what you know they have to go
go through down there but it's still a
very strange and surreal sight being
being in the city not being in a really
what as an island divided
he denies they do surprise you know what
happened
you made a man sunrise you at night do
dynamite and the same he got a hold on
tight with all this fight nice a little
more I'm gonna leave alone
he's a king your queen